my basic message for scotland remains
the same as it has been
please stay at home except for essential
purposes
i have made clear however that scottish
government will keep what
constitutes an essential purpose under
review and i told you last week that we
were considering making
one immediate change a change to the
guidance relating to
exercise and i can confirm that the
scottish cabinet met
earlier this afternoon and agreed a
change to that guidance
at present you're only permitted to
leave home to exercise
once every day from tomorrow that once a
day limit
will be removed so if you want to go for
a walk
more often or to go for a run and also a
walk later on in the day
then you can now do so it is
important to stress that this new advice
will not apply if you
or someone in your household has
symptoms of the virus or if you
received a letter explaining that you
are in the shielded group in those cases
the advice is still to stay at home
at completely and not go out at all
and for everybody all other lockdown
restrictions remain in place
when you are exercising you must stay
relatively close to your own home
and at all times at least two metres
away from people from other households
and although the rules permit exercise
such as walking or running or cycling
they do not yet
extend to outdoor leisure activities
such as sunbathing
picnics or barbecues the fact that you
are
allowed to exercise from tomorrow more
than once is
definitely not and i want to stress this
point a license to start meeting up in
groups
at the park or at the beach doing that
really does risk spreading this virus
and it could potentially force us to
reintroduce stricter guidelines
or toughen up the regulations and
penalties in future